most of the commercials feature Ronald's
doing something to outsmart and stop one
of the villainous characters from
stealing McDonald's food which again is
readily available to be picked and eaten
in nature one of these commercials
features Ronald pulling items out of a
magic Top Hat it's not outside the
typical scope of work for clowns to
perform magic but what is striking is
that this is basically the only kind of
performance that he does up to this
point we haven't seen him juggling
riding a unicycle miming or doing any
other activities typically associated
with being a clown Ronald could easily
have chosen to make him self a hamburger
magician but he didn't do that why
because he wants to appeal to kids he's
constantly saying things to make himself
seem more relatable to kids who he
constantly refers to as the boys and
girls now McDonald's everywhere will
have plenty of scrumptious cherry pies
for boys and girls to enjoy anytime
since Penny wise seems to be modeled
after Ronald it's probably safe to use
it as a reference its power literally
comes from consuming the kid' fear take
all of you